i work here at the council a couple of
housekeeping things
please um remember that this is on the
record this meeting
and you're supposed to turn off those
blackberries
and iphones that go bleep and mess up
the sound system
i guess if you have a samsung device the
apple lawyers will be waiting for you on
the mezzanine
level um we have a
great group for this world economic
update meeting uh i guess we have the
old timers in the old old timer
vincent reinhardt over there on
on the far side from morgan stanley is
of course a regular here
ditto louis alexander from nomura in the
middle
and john nitzke was a kind of anchor
the person of this meeting series when
uh it was going a while ago and he
is now at sice um and
was just recently at the number two at
the international monetary fund
so we obviously have from the size of
the audience a good appreciation of the
quality of the panel
we may also have an appreciation of the
precariousness
of the economy this could be a leading
indicator um
and it it it it runs obviously from the
meeting in
uh europe going on right now uh to next
week's meeting at the fed
uh to questions about the chinese
slowdown and we'll try and get into all
that but i thought we'd start with
europe since um the sort of the delta on
that may be
maybe the biggest uh and it would be
unfair to predict
normally you can ask economists to
predict things if they're not going to
be
disproved for at least 47 minutes
but in this case i guess the press
conference uh
from draghi will be in about half an
hour so i won't ask for predictions
but i'll ask it in a different way i'll
say
vincent if if there is
some kind of indication that there will
indeed be
bond purchases at the short end
from the european central bank to
support programs of countries that do
have programs
how much do you really get out of that
and then let me put the question this
way is the contrast with the
electro's that the ecb did
at the end of last year in the beginning
of this year with the el tros
the ecb jammed the trillion euros of
liquidity
into the banks in two operations so you
could see the money in the banks
in this case what the ecb is saying it
seems
is we will support on a conditional
basis uh
economic reform programs but will stop
in mid-stream
at such time as they don't comply with
the economic conditions
so it's a very conditional promise how
much confidence
will investors do you think get out of
that uh so first
with regards to the long-term lending
repurchase operations
uh it is true they were delineated
but they were also indirect they were
indirect government support because they
required financial institutions to then
use those funds
to support governments and it is true
that over the ltro period uh banks
in italy and spain bought more
government debt than their governments
issued
what may be happening and i hope you've
all turned your blackberries off so that
i'm not wrong by the time the sentence
ends is the
ecb is showing a willingness to build a
bridge
you emphasize the lack of specificity
i think market participants will
emphasize the open-ended
nature of it that is the bridge will be
as
long as it takes for uh politicians
to build the infrastructure required to
make it a more durable institution
they have a lot of heavy lifting to do
they're in no way
shape or form is it a guarantee that
they will accomplish it
but i think the open-ended part is the
is is
is what you should emphasize not the
lack of specificity
well that would suggest and maybe i'll
go to um lewis next
that would suggest that when when draghi
says i'll do whatever it takes
people really believe it uh i mean they
think he's not going to say
you know whatever it takes on condition
that etc
uh there's been so many pledges that
have proved to be disappointing
why do you think lewis do you agree that
this one has a different quality to it
that
whatever it takes really means whatever
it takes that we will be there to
support a program
as long as it's needed i i do agree
because i think what's inherent in what
they're talking about
is an evolution of the constraints that
the ecb
sees on its own policies i think in the
past this sort of direct support for
sovereigns was sort of viewed as beyond
the pale and you're seeing a kind of an
evolution of how the ecb sees its core
mandate
that allows it to build that bridge and
i think that's a very important
um change uh for the better it's also
important in terms of the constraints
in terms of the critics on the ecb board
and the degree to which they
create a kind of a veto uh over any sort
of more active policy
if in fact what we learned today is that
or
in the next couple days is that the ecb
is prepared to go ahead
even though there are a prominent
minority
that sort of is is in opposition to this
that's again a very important easing of
constraints on how they can respond
which i think is very important and so
uh look we'll
as vince said this can go wrong in all
sorts of ways and and
this is no guarantee of the ultimate
outcome but i do think this is
marks an important change well let me
put on the table and get from john a
reaction on this
um one way in which it could go wrong
and that is it seems to me supposing
spain agrees to come forward and ask for
a program which of course they haven't
done yet
but if the politics allows for that to
happen
then spain is eligible for this
purchases of sovereign bonds
but you still have a situation where
deposits
are fleeing the spanish banking system
so banks are you know constrained in
terms of
how much they can extend credit the
price of credit is very high in
spain and that seems to me to to suggest
a very painful uh route out of
recession you know can a program work in
the face
of if if if the public sector in the ecb
is supporting the sovereign
but the banks are credit constrained can
you can you work your way out
well let's come back to what vince said
that there's a lot of heavy lifting
that's going to be involved and that's
for sure
it strikes me there's a lot of attention
being paid to the ecb and that's
that's reasonable and sensible
they're the folks who when the crunch
comes can show up in the morning with a
lot of cash at the
at the window but i would focus more on
the other things that are
that the ecb said its actions are
conditional upon
and those are very non-trivial one we
should remember that
uh on september 12th there are two
important decisions that are coming up
one
the dutch election and second german
constitutional court
i i would have been surprised if the ecb
was going to be very specific about what
it would do
in advance of the german court's
decision which
bears on the legality of the european
stability mechanisms
actions to provide among other things
direct support
to sought to banks not going through the
sovereigns
so the ecb says we're willing to step up
and do what it takes if
if country x engages in
an adjustment program hasn't specified
what that means
uh obvious question does that mean an
imf program or not an imf program second
will the esm be ratified and will it be
active
in uh providing direct support to the
banking system
eg in a country like spain so in a way
although the attention has been on the
ecb and what it might and might not do
it strikes me that it's the
preconditions the ecb action that is
really the critical issue
the quality of the program in its nature
the ability of the esm to provide
direct support to banks what about so
maybe i'll
persist in this question my scenario
with deposit flight in spain
vincent lewis do you want to weigh in on
that
look it's um it's obviously a sort of an
important issue
that if it continues is ultimately going
to be something that could
sort of drive this um i think the points
john made are are absolutely right and
there's a lot of other things going on
one of the other things he didn't
mention was we've got the
european banking union coming up that's
also sort of an important piece of how
this all goes for which bears
so essentially if you if they can
construct
this banking union which will include
the infrastructure that allow you to do
deposit insurance
those are sort of important micro
elements for how you deal all of these
and those things are fundamentally
uncertain
so there's a you know i agree with you
know on both sides there's an awful lot
of moving p
pieces here that have to go forward i
would come back to the notion though
that
like in the sense of what's changed over
the last month
to me the biggest change is a different
attitude on the part of the ecb in the
in terms of the way it sees it mandates
and i think that's material in terms of
the potential outcomes i i mean the
basic question you have to ask yourself
is
what is the euro about was it a social
decision or is an economic decision
if it was a social decision then it
basically tells you that politicians
have an unlimited pain threshold
they understand their voters and they're
representing their interests
if it's an economic decision then
deposit flows do matter they have to
worry about the
uh the consequences for growth they have
to worry about the consequences for
support of their
their sovereign their their their
national financial champions
and at some point some on some future
weekend
leadership will get a phone call that
surprises them and
they may make a different decision than
they made previously
it really does rely on what is your
vision of the future
did they go into this as a social
decision or an economic one
but vince does it doesn't have to be an
either or isn't the part of the
complication that the answer is
is it this or that the answer is yes
it's social
and it's economic and financial so you
could fully
it depends on what what is the end game
what do you see as
a future and you can see european
unification in the end
on a north-south axis or in east-west
axis
the north-south axis is italy which is
basically two regions
with a common flag held together by
transfers from the
rich to the poor but you could argue
plausibly that
both regions haven't pulled up the total
on the other hand east
west is europe is german unification two
regions
pulled together large transfers from the
rich to the poor
and 12 14 years later you say
both pulled each other together uh if
in the end the whole idea of europe was
a social decision
to bring about the better economic one
then the costs now of bearing with the
crisis are probably
manageable if on the other hand it is
still
an almost unlimited uh uh sequence of
transfers
to stitch the whole thing together
that's a much
different determination but in some
sense the fact that you even have to
pose this question
is it a social project or is it an
economic project
you're saying that you don't know the
answer and nor do any of us when we know
it
we're kind of looking and to the extent
that we don't know which it is
there is uncertainty about policymaking
and there's uncertainty about the
sort of uh determination with which
something like draghi's pledge
will be played out over the over the
extended period of months and that's
exactly the fuel on their speculative
attack of a currency union
if you're not sure of of the motives
behind the design of the principal then
financial markets are going to take a
run on the institution
and they're going to find out whether
the pain threshold of politicians is
limited around it
and i could just it's a it's
i think interesting to think about
german unification in this context
um wall came down on november 9th 1989
the monetary union was implemented on
july 1 1990 in full political unif
unification was on october 3rd 1990
in less than a year they went from a
cold start
to full integration and that obviously
the fact that they were able to do that
and
very well not flawlessly but extremely
well
suggests that the institutional
constraints over doing those kinds of
things are not the real issue
what of course lay behind that was a
more or less
instant political consensus around where
you were going in the end
right that was almost from the beginning
never in doubt and in some sense the the
question vince is raising just in the
in the way you framed it is we don't
have that here
and you know the the more you hear
european politicians sort of struggle
around what really is the political
commitment to the end game
you sort of all of those doubts come
back i mean
one prism or one example of these doubts
about whether the project has
really got the political oomphs behind
it to work i guess is this question of
banking
union because there is talk of a banking
union there is talk that this is the
quid pro quo for
allowing the esm daylight fund to help
the banks directly
but the definition of banking union goes
from
sort of the fig leaf of european central
bank supervision
of the biggest banks which is one
version of it
through um sort of european central bank
supervision of all european banks
and then finally at the extreme to
deposit insurance which
implies such a sort of fiscal potential
fiscal transfer that i think most people
think it's
politically implausible uh at least in
the next
period so how do you see this john i
mean isn't there
so much uncertainty around it but again
right look sebastian let me take a step
back and give
at least some some perspective on this
the two when you think about the
the uh the critical comments or the
doubtful comments about the
sustainability of the project of the mu
project
they really center around two at two
issues number one that the eurozone is
not an optimal currency area
insufficiently economically integrated
and second that it lacks the
the flanking let's call them fiscal or
governmental or governance institutions
necessary to run a currency union
both of those issues were evident to the
participants from day one
the idea was not that there was a doubt
about the
zone being an optimal currency area the
decision was to
try to make it an optimal currency area
and the currency was going to be the
fulcrum that was going to force the
integration and reform
that was going to make in an optimal
currency area
what was not foreseen was that the
mechanisms
of discipline that were supposed to
drive that
which was the the no exit clause for
once you get into euro you can't get out
and the idea was you're forced to adjust
who knew at the time that eg greece
portugal ireland would have access to
huge amounts of credit
at extremely fine terms in other words
it was market discipline that failed
uh primarily uh or at least
significantly in this context secondly
the the problem with the fiscal with the
the government's called the government's
issues which were understood
right from the start that there was as
everybody said there was no clear
consensus about is the ultimate goal a
united states of europe
is the goal on the one hand or is this
just a customs union
well this isn't so dissimilar as many
have pointed out to the to the formation
of the united states
but the here again the idea was let's
not
try to reach agreement on the end result
because there is no consensus but let's
take it a step at a time and let's
develop the institutions necessary
as the problems come up what was not
foreseen was that the the context in
which
huge decisions would have to be taken
was the mother of all financial crises
and emanating essentially from the
united states
so the pressures are far greater than
we're anticipated and they're being
forced into making
big decisions we're going to find out if
they're willing to to make the
sacrifices necessary to sustain it
that's yeah and just to finalize
yesterday uh
bill klein at the peterson institute
presented an interesting study of spain
and italy whether their debt is
sustainable and the conclusion is under
most plausible scenarios the answer is
yes
under those circumstances it would seem
to me
surprising if the project would be
abandoned
in essence in that context uh vincent
next week
we have an interesting meeting for the
fed
one friend of mine who watches it says
that he thinks the variance
in potential outcomes is higher than
most meetings you can remember i don't
know if you agree with that but
tell us how you think about the debates
on
unconventional policy following the
jackson hole speech so i think there's
one undecided member among the fomc
participants that's chairman ben
bernanke
and that's why the variance is is is
higher when you're trying
when you're trying to forecast the
behavior of 12 or 19
the variance shrinks in when it's won
it it it's larger and and
and the reason is because chairman
bernanke cares about a consensus of all
19 policymakers not just the 12 people
who vote because everything you do is
presidential multi-year in nature he
cares about the political legitimacy of
the institution
and does worry about what happens and
what that implies for the probability
of a federal reserve reform act of 2013
which is not
not a trivial possibility and then
third he's got a group of people who are
doubtful of the efficacy
of their policy instruments or their
ability to use them in a not sufficient
magnitude
the last time they set their policy
instrument was in june which was to
extend operation twist
and on the basis of that they forecast
that we would have an unemployment rate
that tracks above their long run
estimate and inflation that was
everywhere below their goal
that tells you it's a it's a policy
making committee resigned to poor
economic performance
and and and doubtful about their
instruments they've got a couple
uh we think that the the natural thing
for them to do is work on interest rate
guidance
that is next week add another year to
their forecast and say
guess what we're trading water for
another year it's appropriate to stretch
out their promise to keep interest rates
low
what they're on the record record for is
extending
uh their uh operation twist their
purchase and sale of treasury securities
to year end
that gives them a perfect opportunity in
december
to revisit their balance sheet in
december
precedent suggests that two out of three
times they'll know who's president of
the united states
they'll know who's running the house
they'll know who's running the senate
they'll have a lot more clarity on the
fiscal cliff
and they'll also have just heard the
opinion of the american people about how
interventionist
they want their policy officials to be
and so they can make a much more
informed decision about their balance
sheet so
rate management to to deal with what is
a pressing problem
unemployment rate too high uh
unacceptable downside risks to inflation
uh but that's that's holding the bridge
until
december where they do balance sheet one
of the things um
lewis in the chairman's jackson hull
speech
was this defense of the idea that
quantitative easing really worked
i think my personal sense from looking
at studies before had been that
it worked the first time in less than
the second time and this sort of
diminishing curve of
um do you seem to be resisting that or
de-emphasizing that
no waiting for the truth size no i i
think it's always been clear that the
first round of qe which came in 2009
when markets were still very disrupted
was naturally going to be more effective
than if you do it under more normal
times
frankly if you go back to 2010 and look
at a speech you made that point then
um so i don't think this notion that
it's it's been less effective
in the more recent times than it was in
the first rounds is anything
particularly surprising
or or new and i i think my you know my
reading of it was that the chairman kind
of went out of his way to stress the
fact that it still is effective
and ultimately that is a tool which they
have available to them to use
as needed i think there's i think it's
pretty clear that they
as been said are frustrated by the fact
that they don't have more effective
tools as a consequence
for that they're looking at everything
they can imagine
that you might do otherwise for example
what the
bank of england is doing with its
funding for lending program
i think there's also this sort of
interest in is there a way to sort of
evolve the communication around rates
or perhaps the way you implement qe that
might make it more effective by tying it
more to economic conditions in the
future
i think while that while those things
are all going on and they are kicking
the tires pretty hard and all of that
i'm i don't think they're likely to come
up with answers that they haven't come
up with before on them
so i think we're sort of basically back
back to those two choices
and essentially that's the way the
chairman framed it i think in
in the way he reviewed the performance
of the last couple of years
these two guys are as expert as anyone
on the workings of the fed
uh reading the the chairman's jackson
hole speech
i thought he made very large claims for
the impact of
qe he said it that that output was three
percent higher and
employment two million higher than it
would have been without those are very
large claims
and i thought if you read his last
sentence i thought that came
of the speech it came as close to a
declarative sentence on future policy as
i think i've ever heard of fed chairman
give
and if the unless there's any i what i
thought it said is unless there's some
change in the economic outlook
we got to do more there's no question
they're leaning forward and
and the presumption is there'll be more
policy accommodation
and the question is what is the right
sequence of that policy accommodation
for central banks and not natural order
as you work on rate management
and then you work on balance sheet so i
i read the last sentence as saying
those things are coming unless the data
are surprisingly uh to the upside and
the
likelihood of that is pretty low wrote a
couple papers with then governor ben
bernanke on
on quantitative easing uh eight
eight eight or nine years ago uh most
things in life have diminishing marginal
returns it's not surprising that qe does
too
qe is a lot like sterilized foreign
exchange intervention
when markets are disorderly when you
don't have a lot of capital when
traders don't have conviction you don't
have the possibility of capital coming
in from other markets
then actions of a central bank can have
large effects
when however markets are orderly when
traders have conviction when there's
possibility of capital coming in from
everywhere
they typically don't have much effect
and
now the last point is
this was a crisis in financial markets
financial institutions it was also a
crisis in economics and finance
our models don't work particularly well
uh the idea that you can
assert one one percentage point
consequence of qe
and then put it into one of those models
and then grind out a solution that says
there are that many more employed as a
consequence
is probably a stretch beyond what we're
capable of
one more question sort of loosely
related to jackson hole
on financial regulation which also came
out there uh
lewis maybe for you i guess the sort of
most striking development in
u.s financial regulation recently was
this decision by the sec to back off
money market funds do you see that as i
mean
we've had some regulation action on
banks
shadow banks much much less money market
funds are a central part of the shadow
ranking system
and the sec is basically saying we we
can't do it does this leave
it's now up to the f-stock or what
happens next
no i i think this is a very important
kind of issue that the fsoc has to
address
in some ways they've made the case um
already that money market funds are a
systemic issue
i think there's been a lot of work on
that a lot of consensus around that some
of it done by
some people in the audience here
and i think now the fact that the sec
has been unable to address this
one of the things f-sock was put in the
place to do was address
these situations where you have a
systemic issue that isn't being
addressed by the primary regulator and
so now this
is very much in the f sox
agenda i think it has to be and there's
obviously
you know a complicated set of questions
about exactly how you do this
how you know one option is to
essentially put it back to the sec by
making a systemic designation for the
activity as a whole
the first response of which would be to
then put the onus on the sec to address
this issue again
which may be the right way to go
alternatively you could actually
designate money market funds as
systemically
important institutions themselves and
have the fed take over
uh sort of the regulatory role but um in
some sense
this is exactly the situation that one
of the situations that dodd-frank was
designed to address
and so i think in in some sense it is a
it is a unique opportunity
uh for that whole structure to
essentially
uh show its worth so i think this is a
this is an important issue
will the opportunity be taken
they
if you look at the first fsoc report
it's very clear that one of the
principal systemic risk issues they
identify as money market mutual funds
i think the situation they are in now
with the sec having not acted
i i think it demands action
and so obviously we're going to see
who's who wins the presidential election
who's
dr who's controlling who's essentially
cheering the f sock going forward
um i think by the just by how long it
takes to work these things through it
probably won't be tim geithner if it was
tim geithner i
feel pretty confident predicting that
they would address it given that
this is going to be probably on somebody
else's watch i'm a little less confident
but
i think the answer is yes just before we
open up
and invite members to join the
conversation i want to put one question
to john about
china and that is that
you know china in some sense has had a
couple of uh
successes in terms of it sort of
perceived participation in the global
economic community one was
right after the lehman brothers
collapsed
there was a global coordinated stimulus
and china contributed
handsomely to that one in terms of
trade imbalances china's trade and
balance has shrunk
a lot so these are two good things
but does strike me now that we've been
discussing
what the central banks could do in
europe
and in the u.s sweden has just cut this
morning i think
there's a lot of action around the world
and yet chinese growth by chinese
standards
has come down a lot and policy action in
china
on some readings of it has been
surprisingly
uh cautious do you think we're kind of
coming up to a moment where
china may be nudged by
uh economic uh leaders in other
countries saying come on you should do
your share here
to prop up global demand interesting
question that
uh of course a central factor two two
key unknowns one is how slow is slow
in china if you take a look for example
at the recently updated uh imf
forecast it's calling for essentially a
soft landing eight to eight and a half
percent growth
uh in china certainly that's not double
digit but that's not shabby either
and in the context of a relative success
in rebalancing the economy
towards stronger growth and domestic
demand uh and less reliance on net
exports because that's consistent
at least in the imf forecast with a
continued current account surplus
under three percent uh which is of
course dramatically down from where it
was before the
uh before the crisis uh the second
unknown but
but they say what's unknown is is that
right is this a soft landing trajectory
in which you'd have to say things are
obviously there's there's difference in
in the
prosperity of given sectors we've seen
the recent manufacturing data in china
suggest a significant slowdown
which would give pause and create
question of whether that soft landing
view is too sanguine
and if so i think there's a general
sense that there are policy levers
available to the chinese authorities if
things are going
much softer than they had anticipated
and
if that is the case then i suspect there
will be not only
uh external calls for policy action but
even more importantly
domestic calls for uh for action in the
context of the second unknown which
is the leadership change that is coming
up in a in a matter of months
uh with the new leadership as i
understand it
on the committed to a
rather activist set of economic policies
along the lines of the 12-5 year plan
already uh adopted as formal policy and
for those who haven't read it if you
read it
i'm sure most folks here would read down
that list and say right right right
right right
it's a liberalization market orientation
etc reform of the fiscal system reform
of the banking system the financial
system
let's see if it all gets done but for
right now
the the key question is how how slow is
slow if this is a soft landing
then they're going to be fine if it's
worse than that then there certainly
will be calls as they say domestically
for
for things to do okay let's see uh
if there's any questions from the
members right here on the aisle the
microphone should be coming
so please speak directly into it and um
marta varela i wanted to ask the
panelists
uh returning to europe to what extent do
you believe that labor market reform
emanating from brussels will be a
significant factor in the fix for
europe's woes
well that's a yeah that's a favorite of
mine
i'll be real quick uh i always called
that vision
i called that the lisbon the lisbon
agenda fallacy
that the notion that market that labor
market reforms begin
with legal changes and then emanate to
market changes
is get things backwards i think how the
how labor legislation changes
is companies become under pressure
they put pressure backwards on their
workforce for improved performance in
in the standard ways and if that rubs up
against legal constraints then their
pressure comes against
to the to the legal authorities to
legislatures to make the appropriate
changes so things can get
can get going i i don't know a very few
times in which i can think of important
changes coming first
at the legislative level without already
having created
without a swell of support from the from
the
let's call the corporate business sector
uh i think that is
happening and of course the place that
is the poster child for that
uh that process it was germany uh under
in the uh schroeder uh government
so i was on a panel the title of which
was the financial crisis in europe
a blessing in disguise the theory being
that market pressure would then lead to
reforms
and that would be so growth enhancing
that they would the
the uh the crisis would pay for itself
my answer was if it's a disguise it's a
very good discount
yeah right yeah
andrew gunlock uh arnold supply shutter
that answer might lead into this next
question which is you really have two
approaches here
uh the u.s approach which is keynesian
and easy money
and the argument is that there hasn't
been enough
spending and the european approach which
is really austrian
there's no credit available and there's
deflation forced upon
most of the population and the question
is
which one if you're not a co economist
but rather financial historians
which one is going to prove to have been
a better approach and what are the
unintended consequences that you worry
about in each
maybe we'll go down the line here and
have a vote from everybody uh
uh so so let's be pointing at other
people he doesn't want to start
well i don't think i don't think
anybody's policy is uh won any gold
stars okay
let's go for this we're going to start
this way so let me give the answer that
lewis won't give so therefore
i wrote a paper with my wife carmen and
ken rogoff both
however looking at the experience since
the napoleonic war of 22 advanced
economies
and here's the the bottom line uh
episodes of debt overhangs where you
have gross debt more than 90 percent
are very costly the growth discount is
on the order of 1.2
slower real gdp growth per year as long
as you're in the debt overhang
that those episodes are very long median
duration is 23 years
so if you wind up with high debt by the
time you get out of it the level of debt
is a
your level of gdp is a quarter lower
than it had been if you never got there
and it isn't always about rates it isn't
about market discipline 11 out of the 26
cases of
significant debt overhangs it wasn't
market discipline forcing that
contraction
it's something else so so um
i understand that the unemployment rate
is high
in many advanced economies unacceptably
high we need more policy accommodation
we have to do that in a way that gets us
to a path
for which we uh have a uh consolidate
our fiscal accounts
if you frame it as u.s versus europe um
one of the crucial crucial crucial
distinctions is of course
the u.s benefits as a safe haven and so
in some sense we
have the flexibility to deal with
vince's problem over time in a way
that other countries don't if you
compare us to greece
right we have the luxury of time in a
way that they don't
and i think that that drives you to
different answers
now the obvious point that
you know in some sense the work that
vince just described creates for the us
is you can't do this forever you do have
to pay attention the long run
there's got to be some sort of solution
that strikes the balance between those
two things
is is i think important but if you look
at where the fiscal debate is in the u.s
at this moment
what's striking about it is it's only
about the pace of consolidation
the in some sense the keynesian side of
that debate is frankly
not in play at the moment
it it really is the question of how
fast we're going to do consolidation
not whether or not we're going to do
stimulus now and
consolidation later and i think that
it certainly affects me as i'm as i'm a
forecaster
but we you know the united states is in
this sort of very different position
um you might argue japan uh somewhat
different circumstances very high
domestic savings rate managed to sort of
face a different set of constraints in
that environment but
i i ultimately agree with vince that
like you have to deal with this problem
and and you can't get around it but
we are operating under somewhat
different constraints
john yeah
which is everything's fine until it's
not fine
but uh i didn't say not pay attention
carmen's study was music to the ears of
the folks at the imf
uh who have uh had this view for for
some time that this is
uh this is how these situations have to
be have to be dealt with
uh but certainly lou is right uh
everything doesn't have to get fixed
today
but it's got to get fixed and and the
key and the key
is and the key is that it has to be that
people have to have confidence
that it will be fixed and that's that's
the tricky part namely
how can you how do you demonstrate
convincingly
that even though you're not fixing
everything at once because you can't
that you will fix it over time you're
talking about specifically about fiscal
deficits among other things
i mean i think one of the one of the
things which i think is important to
think through when you look at the us
right now is if you look at the history
of how we've dealt with these things
to some extent we went through one of
these cycles in the late 80s and early
90s
we got our fiscal accounts on what
seemed like an unsustainable path in the
late 80s
it became a retail political issue it
generated among other things
ross perot running for president now
that
ultimately led to a set of political
choices that put us on the path of where
we were in the late 90s which was
surpluses
now there were other things going on as
well like a surge of productivity growth
and
a variety of other things so it's not it
wasn't all policy choices
but the point i would make is retail
politics in the u.s
drove you to a solution i would argue
we're in the same place
what is more than anything else driving
fiscal policy in the united states right
now is the tea party
right it's driving in the sense that
they are saying
we are on an unsustainable path and we
have to fix it now regardless
of the sort of the keynesian concerns
now
it's amen we have a political system in
which it is hard to get things done
by design our system was designed to
make it hard that's what checks and
balances mean
so it is a messy process for us
to get to that consolidated path and
yes i totally agree with each other
there's got to be confidence in the long
run but i would argue
the thing that ought to give one
confidence is what's driving this is not
market pressure
it's not the imf imposing on it it is
politics on the ground and so yes the
next six months is going to be
incredibly messy
i think there's a decent chance we're
going to go right off the cliff because
people aren't going to be able to make
it
reach an agreement at the end right but
i think
the thing to remember is what's driving
us
more than anything else is retail
politics that wants to get us on the
consolidated path
and i think when you think in the long
run context that's the thing that ought
to give one
some degree of confidence that we're
going to ultimately fix this problem
so there are two constraints on fiscal
policy there's market discipline and
there's voter discipline
when we talk about market discipline it
is like service in the military
long periods of tedium and intense bouts
of panic
could have pointed to greek spreads
three years ago and said there's no
fiscal problem
so but i think lewis is exactly right
locally there's no market discipline on
the united states there is voter
discipline that's why we're seeing
change
thing to remember about voter discipline
is it's mostly incoherent
you look everybody hates deficits and
debt
everybody loves their own programs if
you do the in detailed surveys and ask
how would you fix the problem the first
answer is cut foreign aid
that's what two orders of magnitude off
to
to deal with the problem politics is
about
channeling voter anger to an appropriate
end
uh what i compare this the u.s system is
since we continually
generate voter discipline like like the
little circular rumba
that cleans my living room floor it has
no intelligence it bounces off the walls
eventually it gets the point where it
covers everything we'll get to the right
place
we'll get to the right place it will
take longer
yes uh than it it would if there was an
intelligence guiding the process
so in that sense we're not like japan
where we where there's both an absence
of voter discipline
and market discipline um but it's going
to be expensive
so the the kennedy school political
economy courses will soon have the floor
polishing theory of
u.s decision making um anything more
from
the members who's got a comment or a
question
um otherwise i can see the flow moving
here john yeah i could add something to
what vince said
which is uh in fact uh
there are are even though this uh
vision of the roomba may be not
completely comforting in the short run
that uh that actually there are a number
of factors
that seem quite positive for the us
economy in the medium term
certainly the the energy outlook
which is it's very it's very striking
that
near term you have very high energy
prices and the medium term
the all the experts tell you that the
the outlook for
energy costs in the united states is
differentially favorable
uh not only favorable in absent sense
but favorable in a relative sense
and at the same time we've seen the
corporate sector
uh obviously do significant deleveraging
banking system
significant deleveraging uh the the
underpinnings it seems the financial
underpinnings of the uh
the corporate sector are very sound it's
interesting to me that people talk about
the
paralysis of uncertainty that's a that's
a press favorite
uh in fact as we all know that business
spending on equipment and
in software has actually grown at a at a
at a solid pace
and if everybody was paralyzed with
uncertainty it's sort of hard to
understand how that was
how that was happening uh and at the
same time
even though we still have questions
about the near-term outlook and housing
sector
i think it's it's obvious the trend rate
of new host new new household formation
in the u.s
is probably someplace between a million
and two million a year who knows
uh but it since 2008 we've been
producing about
conceivably half the new uh the new
units that are
necessary to fill sort of the the
generic demand trend
uh all of that suggests that there's uh
there ought to be if we
if we can get the the impediments out of
the way
that the medium-term outlook ought to be
quite
quite satisfactory any questions from
the membership i have one day i see one
over there okay
thank you
it doesn't seem byron wien blackstone it
doesn't seem to me
that we're going to solve this problem
without very significant structural
changes
on both sides of the atlantic there's no
evidence that the democrats are going to
be sufficiently aggressive
in cutting entitlements and there's no
evidence that the republicans are going
to be
sufficiently aggressive in raising taxes
and we're not going to solve the budget
deficit problem
without doing both or at least i don't
think so
so what evidence it seems to me that you
as a panel are too complacent about this
you know that that you think that
eventually you know
uh we'll we'll solve the problems
because we always seem to
but there's there's evidence that we're
in much more trouble
than we've ever been before we had six
trillion dollars in debt
in 2000 we have 16 trillion dollars in
debt
now it's going up at a trillion dollars
more than a trillion dollars
a year and congress won't do anything
about it because
we can borrow money so cheaply they
won't do anything about it in my opinion
until interest rates go up
but by then it'll be too late so i'm
worried there
aren't enough structural there isn't a
motivation for structural change
and the same thing is going on in europe
all they're doing is temporarily
solving the problem there by issue by by
providing funds
they aren't really dealing with the
structural issues they talk about it
but if you look at what's going on in
italy and spain it's just not
enough so my feeling is you're too
complacent am i being too critical
um i i'm not gonna
i think that was mainly directed to me
and not my two colleagues who were i
think
less complacent than your scale than i
was um
first of all let me agree that
the circumstances are much worse than
they were in the 1980s and
the concerns that both these guys
expressed about right if we were get to
the
if we were to get to the point where the
market paid attention
to long-run sustainability in the united
states that is a very big deal that none
of us wants to deal with number one
number two um there is no question that
we are headed
in a kind of a political environment
that is very contentious and very
partisan
with both sides taking out positions
that are that are hard to move
but i think i would i would point to the
following signs
for somewhat more optimism first of all
it's
clear from all the reporting that the
president and
and uh speaker boehner came pretty close
to a significant deal
last summer that included um significant
changes on entitlements on the part of
the president and some revenues on the
part of the republicans
now that you know that obviously that
deal did not come forward but there is a
basis for some optimism that
they've worked through the details
closely enough to sort of think about
those options
second of all i take as progress the
fact that
um chairman ryan has put forward a
budget that has a
actually involved going out and getting
the congress to vote on spending cuts
that are you know non-trivial right
they're not necessarily what i would
choose
uh but the fact that they've taken the
action of
actually forcing the congress to vote on
those things is a sign of
of some movement in this area
i think this is something that is going
to take multiple years to get us there
and i would come back to the notion that
ultimately what is driving us
is a dissatisfaction on the part of the
american voters and the fiscal path we
are on
and that that is going to be reflected
as it has
already been reflected through our
elections that is
i think how you how i take you know what
happened in 2010 more than anything else
and so i think you're going to see that
reflected uh
going forward and so um look i
the one of the things i've spent a fair
amount of time thinking about is
systemic risk
and the sort of the mother of all
systemic risk is if you get to the point
where you see some transition away from
u.s treasuries
as the safe haven asset there is nothing
that tops that in my mind as a systemic
risk now
having gone through what we went through
in 2009
i mean i you know where every every
in every day when we had a bad day at
that point
i checked to make sure that treasuries
rallied
because the day when you have a bad day
and risk and treasuries don't rally
is the really bad day i i
have to admit i kind of look at what's
happened over the last three years and i
kind of asked myself the question
okay like what is it going to take for
foreign investors to look up and say
they don't want to own treasuries and i
i don't want to get there and i want to
do everything to prevent us from getting
there
but it's hard not to look at what we've
come through and
argue that there's some resilience there
so i really i really am flattered that i
could be on panel and viewed as an
optimist
and and i think that
my statement isn't about any local
optimism i think it's just a mistake
to uh under count a a market economy
that historically has been very
resilient
and so historically we've risen to the
challenges
we have to make as a nation three
realizations
number one the average tax rate has to
go up
number two you don't necessarily get the
average tax rate up by raising marginal
tax rates in an inefficient tax system
number three the biggest overvalued
asset
in the world right now is the net
present value of entitlements that our
our citizens think they're going to get
because we don't have a
a fiscal system that can actually
deliver that those are
three really hard things it isn't
obvious to me that we have a political
system that generates those solutions
really fast
if you want to look for good news the
good news is this election is most
likely going to be count
be contested on two distinct visions of
fiscal policy the even better news is we
are in terrible at delivering fiscal
policy right now
we are so far inside the efficient
frontier of fiscal policy
that any which way is up and so it is
possible to define two distinct coherent
credible visions for what we should do
that get us to a better place
they differ on your viewing the size of
the government the mark
you know the progressivity of tax system
the role the role of the safety net
but we can do it and we just have to
we'll get there eventually
uh it may wind up being very very costly
and it could be a close run thing
okay here's my bit the uh uh
look it seems to me that they're they're
uh
there are several factors here that uh
obviously there's set
of downside risks here downside risk in
europe
particularly evident in europe but
it seems to me first of all there is
a notion public say a
popular notion that the rise in debt and
deficit in the united states
was due almost entirely to discretionary
decisions by the us government
which is simply not the case most of the
rise in debt and deficit reflects
the weakness the weak performance of the
economy automatic stabilizers
at the same time even though federal and
as a result
the deficit ought to be geared towards a
renormalization of the economy
it'll improve if the economy uh in fact
in fact improves and i think it gave
a couple reasons why you'd think that
that's a that's
still likely there is a window but at
the same time i would say there is a
real window of opportunity
for improvement in fiscal policy that if
it is not met
is a real danger and it's easy to define
federal debt as percent of gdp has
increased by 50 since the beginning of
the crisis
and federal debt service as a percent of
gdp
has increased by zero since the since
the beginning of the crisis
this is not going to last forget the
forget
anybody losing faith in treasuries if
there's a renormalization
of inter of the economy and a
renormalization of real interest rates
federal debt service as a percentage gdp
is going to go up by two to two and a
half percent in the next by the end of
the next administration so if they don't
make progress
toward improving the medium-term fiscal
outlook in the next two years it's going
to come back and eat them alive
because they're going to be struggling
to hold the deficit down just paying the
debt
so this isn't going to this isn't going
to go away and
myron you may be right that the that
congress is there
everyone's too myopic to do anything
about it i i hope you i hope you're
wrong
uh and it's uh let's see what happens
in europe i would say uh
the the short version is is there a plan
i'd say the answer is yes there is an
explicit plan on what they should be
doing
what you're basically seeing is an
argument about who's gonna pay
and i just don't think it's uh it makes
sense or is reasonable to to um
expect that there while they argue about
who's gonna pay the bill they're gonna
go over the cliff
i.e as i call it the wiley e coyote
moment uh
it could happen could happen but
as as you can see some decisions have
been made in europe over the past few
months that a year ago would have seemed
impossible now it doesn't mean it's
gonna it's gonna succeed
but i think there's there's reason for
thinking
the heavy lifting that we started out
with vince talking about is in fact
going to get done
one more question i saw somebody earlier
just there and yeah
hi david malpass with encima global we
haven't talked about taxes so we have a
tax cliff at year end
uh if as vince says average versus
marginal rates does that inevitably get
us to consumption
taxes as the population ages
um i don't think inevitably um that's
obviously one solution i think
just following up on john's list of good
things one of the things that i'm
encouraged by is all the
discussion that's actually going on
about fundamental tax reform that's sort
of
that's part of but really independent of
the fiscal story
and i i think we have a tax code that is
very inefficient i think you've had
the president's come out with a white
paper supporting essentially risk
revenue neutral corporate tax reform
you've got the house
doing hearings on that now which is the
necessary preparatory work
so even in a even in a kind of a world
where obama gets reelected and you have
a republican congress
i think there's a decent chance we're
going to get fundamental tax reform and
i'd add that on to
the list of john's things um
does that do we ultimately get to a
consumption tax
i i i'm an economist so i can certainly
make the argument for why we're there
i don't think that's really part of the
debate right now we're we're a fair
a fair way away from that uh but we'll
see um
i do think one of the risks which i
think uh
people are sort of discounting is the
notion that first
for essentially bargaining and strategic
reasons we will go off the fiscal cliff
right in the sense that the advantage of
doing that is then the tax rates reset
back to where they were at the beginning
of the bush administration
and then you could have a different
debate which is a debate about
let's do a big tax reform that includes
cutting taxes for most people
and that is a more attractive debate for
both sides to have
than the current one and so i
and you know there's a lot of work been
done of like what's the economic
consequences of going off the cliff well
a lot depends on whether or not you
think it's permanent or temporary if you
think you
you roll into jan one with no deal and
all of those things are there forever
that's a very bad world but i would
argue
that's a bad assumption um if we go on
the cliff there will be a set of
negotiations that will
get us a big tax bill early in the year
that will
make changes i don't think that's going
to include a consumption tax
would be my prediction uh but
i do think actually tax reform over the
next year
is one of the sort of potential upsides
so we should say a consumption tax
layered on top of an efficient of a
already inefficient tax system should be
very frightening
a consumption tax part of a total reform
should be welcomed let me just uh wrap
this up with
asking for a one word answer from each
of you
surely in three years time
uh how many members of the eurozone will
there be you're allowed to say
17 16 or fewer
john 17.
16 or fewer fewer okay
consensus thank you very much
in four